[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the Sept of Baelor a shrine
to bad front office decisions the kind
that have led all of you here to the
draft lottery today we gather in the
presence of the lottery guards to
witness the bestowing of the first peek
I am Marc Tatum hand of the High
Commissioner wears a silver lord
[Music]
yes actually and besides this is sort of
my thing yeah you know what let's just
take a moment to appreciate Marc Tatum
that's right let's give it a love to the
guy behind the guy okay all right thanks
as per tradition each house has chosen
one delegate to represent them I do
question some of your delegate choices
but then again questionable decisions
are why many of you find yourselves here
housed pelicans come on you know who the
foundlings want to see that's better
um excuse me house Mavs what is this
we're uh triple ducks okay well you got
to pick one representative so figure out
who is the next Dirk in the next ten
seconds please all right well I mean I'm
the most experienced well I'm clearly
the face of House Mavericks and I'm from
darks hometown so yeah I mean it's hard
we all have really good cases all right
you know what how did you guys sort this
out next season House Lakers okay so we
are all good everyone knows how this
works
oh not really right well each house will
have a chance to make their final pleas
with lottery guards as to why they
should get the first pick so who would
like to be the first to make a claim
great the goat was made poop on the
floor excuse me no not you sarva why is
a goat here because
it's a metaphor and it's funny okay well
please send a new representative down
preferably a human okay
the floor is open Oh take a stop here I
would say to the gods that you should
give house Kings the first pick because
actually now it would go to the sixes
oh crap yeah okay gods
you should give house Kings the second
pick now then it would go to you house
Celtx I believe wait what
who made I made this stuff okay do
someone else no house has fallen harder
than that of the grizzly circus all is
gone but Chandler Parsons and his stupid
contracts remain could be worse bless us
Oh lottery guards with the squire Zion
so that grit and grind may rise again as
a bane to all Western powers the great
house NYX has not had a first pick in
over 30 years
Lord 50 we finally have cast off or
overrated European big man to make room
for the great side please gods take that
for data and give our snicks the first
pitch oh yeah please House Knicks get
shy and they'll just send them away in
another terrible trade all right you sir
Chris tops are now banned from the
garden okay you can't just ban an
opposing Knight from your arena does
anyone else want to make a plea to the
gods
ah so Devon welcome screw her sons they
rejected our alliance and stole the
first pick from us last year
yeah dowry of Luca honey don't wait who
did you guys take think Trey young uh
what no we took to Andre Aten oh yeah
how's he been this year it's actually
pretty solid yeah yeah it's quietly had
a decent square sees Sir Anthony Davis
you want to make a plea for house
pelicans yes read this and we will trade
you two house Lakers right okay let's
try this again
we house pelicans are but a humble house
and we kindly ask you for your blessing
Zion is the hero that house pelicans
need
a knight who could take us further than
one playoff series win in seven seasons
we once had a transformative all-around
night but he lacked the fortitude to
take the fortitude it takes to commit to
a small mark okay it's my fault that I
sorry I couldn't beat house warriors
with Drew holiday and half a season of
boogie cousins um thank you ad house
Cavs would you like to make your case if
the gods truly care to see the Squires
iron flourish they should give the first
big to house Cavs well he will be
surrounded by championship caliber
veterans and the Lord who knows how to
win oh please you know there's a reason
I left twice oh yeah because you've made
house Blake is such a welcoming place
for young talent I'm spitting out now
hey Kevin yes LeBron I miss you I I miss
you too
all right guys let's maybe keep the
overt tampering to a minimum okay then
who's next house Hawks wait free house
he has to go oh yes
house Hawks please go ahead empty
lottery guards our house is on the rise
is our joins are maybe a 42 year old
Vince Carter won't have to play 17
minutes of battle okay who else in SOTA
I mean how many number one picks do you
guys need to make the tournament
apparently more than three this is fun
hey do us know who else house Wizards I
mean who wouldn't want to play with
Dwight Howard by the way when does John
wolves Supermax start next year asking
for friend okay who else we got how
schools oh yeah I'm sure lion wants to
spend his first year having okay show a
little respect for many of these houses
this is the highlight of their season
yeah oh yeah why is that maybe instead
of looking to the gods you all should be
looking at yourselves
rubbish houses with uninspiring Lord
commanders foolish masters of trade
arrogant Lords
you're bad these are things at night no
matter how great can't overcome I
learned that the hard way
Zion may be the prince who was promised
but he will not save you because if you
don't give a goat the support he needs
Bernice gonna walk out the door and all
you're gonna be left with poop on the
floor all right well on that note why
don't we go ahead and see what the first
pick and the winner of the zion lottery
is House Pelican
[Music]
so the kids getting notifications about
new episodes of gamer zones is by
clicking the subscribe button ok so I
move my cursor to the subscribe button
yes but is merely a pump fake no I open
a new tab I search beanie mellow and I
read the comments on my workout videos
that's exactly what you shouldn't do